I told Brian this is no surprise I said
I just fundamentally disagree with your
concept of this character and how you
use him one thing in the documentary
that that kept coming back up was you
saying that you fundamentally disagree
with Rian Johnson's I'll tell you why
because that should remain in the
rehearsal process that should be between
the screenwriter and the director and I
regret saying that out loud and I said
it before I saw the whole movie put
together and it's it prejudices people
in a way that's unfair because people
that are unhappy with the movie you know
will cite that say see yeah and look I
mean it's it was unexpected
you know because Luke was always so
optimistic and and positive and and but
you know it's gotta move on I mean I do
like the unexpected and that was
certainly unexpected and even though
it's hard when you're pushed out of your
comfort zone that's probably a good sign
because otherwise it would be you know
something that everyone had expected and
that that's that's not good
and when you see you know starting and
ending with the two sons that was like
okay well there you are
and so JJ provided one of the most
spectacular entrances well certainly a
my career maybe in all of film history
and Ryan gave them this the send-off
that you know that also has such meaning
for people so you know how can I
complain I had a beginning a middle and
an end once and then I had a beginning
and an end no middle just but that's
fine
[Music]